among the demigod children of queen
marika the eternal
none is more mysterious than mikala the
unalloyed
not only is he not an enemy in the game
yet
but he is described by melania to be the
most fearsome of all the imperials
and so mysterious is he
that even sir gideon the all-knowing
knows very little about him
but what do we know about mikala
well we know a few things
mikala and his twin sister melania are
emperians
which means they were born from a single
god
and that god is marika and ranigan who
are one and the same
and like his twin melania mikhaila is
also cursed
while melania suffers from the scarlet
rot
mikala suffers from eternal youth
but this did not stop both siblings from
becoming fearsome demigods
while melania would become undefeated
with her blade
mikala would seek knowledge
he created an incantation known as the
discus of light
and gifted them to his father ratagan
the incantation that he created is
actually quite interesting as well it
appears as a simple halo of light that
does damage but it's considered an
incantation of the golden order
fundamentalists
which makes it quite unique
in the game holy incantations from the
golden order are often associated with
healing and curing status ailments and
the few incantations they have that
focus on the offense
are made specifically for those who
oppose the golden order
for instance orders blade and litany of
proper death is meant to deal with those
who live in death while the discus of
light works well with any creature
making the incantation somewhat unique
radigan would return the favor by
gifting mikala with another incantation
known as radigan's rings of light an
incantation that seems like an enhanced
version of the discus of light but
instead of it being fired it appears
from the caster's body instead
unfortunately this wasn't what mikala
was expecting
despite all the healing incantations the
order had
none of them would work on melania's
scarlet rot
and because of this mikala abandoned the
fundamentalism
and began his own
here was the birth of annaloid gold
mykolo would gather his followers to
head north past the village of ordina
this land would be the beginning of
something new
he sought to create his own earth tree
planting a seed and feeding it with his
own blood
this would later be known as nicholas
heilig tree
here mikala and his followers would
create the city of el phil
and it would become a haven for those
who aren't chosen by the greater will
and the golden order
the path towards the healing tree is not
an easy one
the path is a trial on its own and many
try to find the new tree
but it is hidden and only those who are
able to enter the consecrated snow field
are able to make the journey to the
hailing tree
our journey involved finding two pieces
of a medallion in order to enter the
consecrated snow field
if you didn't just stumble on it on your
own your journey would be accompanied by
two others
millicent who is on her quest to find
melania although your meetings are more
of coincidence
and latina who knows the location of the
second half of the medallion and simply
wants to go home to ordina
the first half of the medallion was in
the village of the albinorics
this village was destroyed by ensha in
order to find the medallion
but despite slaughtering everyone in the
village they weren't able to find the
first half of the medallion
fun fact
you would be given a hint about this by
a finger reader in the academy gate town
please
hide your fingers please your fingers
oh
bless you
michaela's favor can be yours
slaughtered
but alas it was for naught
but all you need to
is snatch it
from the big pot
[Music]
[Music]
we find the first half of the medallion
by finding old albus hidden in a pot
he noticed us different from the other
tarnish that destroyed the village and
entrusted the medallion to us
at this point when you return to the
round table hold you will be attacked by
enshaw for having the first half of the
medallion
after slaying him and talking with
guinean he will tell you to seek out
latina
as an apology for the whole business
with insha
and as mentioned upon meeting latina she
will tell you the location of the second
half of the medallion which is deep in
castle seoul
she will also implore you to take her
with you to make a less hailing tree
but what does the village of the
albanorics have to do with the hailik
tree
well some of the albanorics were led to
the healing tree by royal knight loretta
in order to have them settle there as a
safe new home
and it might have been heard that left
half of the medallion in the village
a mistake for drew those who would seek
nicholas favor
and it is here that he would begin his
research and experiments on quelling the
scarlet rot
but the rot isn't so easily removed as
it is no ordinary disease
it is a curse from an unnamed outer god
beings of great power that can influence
the lands between
in fact the golden order serves an outer
god
known as the greater will but since the
greater will could not help his sister's
rotting body michaela would use his own
power to do so
michelle would create analog gold
needles which would ward away the
meddling of outer gods
the perfect version of these needles
could even be used to cheat faith
and completely render its bearer immune
to the will of an outer god
this would ultimately grant relief to
those affected by the scarlet rot
albeit only temporary it would not
completely take away the rot nor would
it cure it
it would simply abate it
still
it says a lot about nicola's
capabilities for him to be able to go
against the outer gods
but what else do we know about his
capabilities
well interestingly
mikala has an ability to make others
infatuated with him making them faithful
towards him
it is unsure if this ability is due to
his curse or if it's his own power
but eventually he learned how to use
this power to bewitch those around him
this could even be the reason why he was
stolen away by mog the lord of blood
something we'll get into in a bit
now what's interesting about this power
is that most humans in the helic tree
are affected by it
if we take a look at their helmets
they're all made from unalloyed gold
and they all increase faith by one
to me this shows that the humans of the
healing tree are somewhat bewitched by
mikala
compelling them to be more faithful
towards him
now as i mentioned earlier he was stolen
away by mog
but what does that actually mean when
the hailing tree was growing in an
attempt to make it into an earth tree
mikala bonded with the tree growing
within it but mog cut out the womb of
the hailing tree in which michela was in
if you visit the roots of the hailing
tree after defeating melania you can
even still see the hole where he was cut
out from the tree itself would resemble
a body but part of it has been cut out
mog stole mikala in an attempt to ascend
him to godhood and become his consort we
can actually find mikhaila in his cocoon
form with mog
but we can't interact with him even
after we slay the lord of blood
and even gideon was vexed that he didn't
know that any of this occurred
and while mikala is certainly still
alive
he is dormant and asleep
now you might ask how could this happen
if melania was undefeated and is
probably one of the most powerful
demigods there is
how could she let mog still mikkel
well during the fight with radon melania
used up a lot of her vitality in order
to infect radon with the scarlet rot
effectively defeating him
this actually put melania to sleep ever
since their fight
and the only reason she was able to
leave the scarlet ionia alive is thanks
to one of the legendary clean rot
knights finlay
who we can actually summon as spirit
ashes
it reads that finlay carried melania all
the way to the heilig tree alone
these two events melania's slumber and
michaelis kidnapping actually hindered
their growth into godhood
as both siblings were closest to
becoming gods
melania only needed to bloom once more
and mikala needed to awake from his
transformation
lastly there was actually some cut
content about saint trina you might have
noticed some items in the game that goes
by the prefix saint trina such as saint
trina's arrows sword lily and a torch
in that cut content it was revealed that
saint trina and mikala were one in the
same
and those infatuated with saint trina
would eventually find their way to serve
mikala
sir gideon is still unsure what to do
with the cocoon of mikala
but should he wake from his slumber
to find all his siblings now perished
and a new elden lord crowned
what horrors could the most fearsome of
the imperials do
hey everyone arlun here thank you so
much for watching i am absolutely in
love with the world of elden ring and
i'm planning to make more of these lore
videos for the channel don't worry about
gentian that is still coming once the
next patch drops but with regards to the
video that is basically all i found out
with mikala the unalloyed he is so
interesting as a demigod i
want to see more of him and hopefully
maybe he has something to do with the
age of absolute ending if it's real
if you know anything else about mikala
that i missed please let me know in the
comments down below i really want to
know more about mykola or if i made a
mistake feel free to leave a comment
about that as well but yeah i am going
to be making a little more elven ring
content so if you like that please don't
forget to like and subscribe and as
always thank you for watching